to be honest i i can't stand learning in
a structural
processing of any kind of education so
for me it was just a relief
i finally was able to to to shine by
studying by myself
you don't have anyone to hold you up or
to push you too much
and you know most of the things to be
honest you can easily learn by yourself
when it comes to computer science
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
it's just unbelievable how quickly the
health tech space
is helping transform the healthcare
system all over the world
in just an explosion of new technology
new regulations
and new insights meet david maman the
founder and ceo of bina ai
an innovative and successful startup
that is transforming the way healthcare
services are being delivered and
consumed
david is spearheading the bina ai team
towards its mission to make healthcare
services available to anyone
anywhere anytime using its award-winning
technology
bina ai allows users to extract vital
signs and mental stress levels
just by looking at a smartphone tablet
or laptop camera
as serial entrepreneur david is
currently leading his 13th
startup after driving numerous startups
from vision to international success
including hexathier acquired by wowwee
pricos
green vandumsoft tourideon and more
david maman
rock and roll welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you very much for having
me it's a pleasure being with you
michael
i'm very excited to have you here the
founder and ceo of bina ai that is doing
really
you know in my mind that i'm sharing the
mind of millions
really really important work especially
in 2021
and and what we're seeing the world
unfold with accessibility to to wellness
and to health and to health care
and you know a lot of one thing that i
that i'm always understanding is that
i'm living in this beautiful beautiful
place whether it be tel aviv or
california
and you know i'm so lucky to have all
this infrastructure
that i can even call you know doctors
and i can and i can get this input but
most people around the world can't
and so and so i'm excited to hear from
you a little bit deeper into the
industry but even before we dive into
health tech and
and accessibility tell me a little bit
about david because
just simply going through your
experiences on linkedin i started
hyperventilating from how many things
you've done and all the incredible
experiences
walk me through some of the highlights
that sort of shaped who you are as a
thinker and as an entrepreneur
i guess i was uh well first of all thank
you
never hyperventilate because of me okay
i don't want to take this responsibility
but i think that in a very high level i
guess i was always extremely intrigued
by technology
you know my previous uh tagline in
linkedin was
a technology junkie that's what i am i
am a hardcore technology junkie
i'm always into innovation i'm always
about thinking about how to create
something or how to optimize something
you know it's a
it's an interesting combination of
entrepreneurship
many of us just improve something that
is currently available doesn't matter if
it's a product the service
and some of us just create something
from nothing and i guess i was always
intrigued between those two worlds of
trying to create something from nothing
and also how we can actually optimize
the world we're living in
whether it's a product or something else
and i think that
i started like i was brought
up in the north of israel in a small
city called yoknam now it's actually a
major city back then it was 4 000 people
and nothing was available you know i had
one library some people don't really use
libraries anymore but back then we had
to go to a library to consume some
some sort of information uh and i was
always intrigued on
finding new ideas and new stuff i was a
very troubled kid to be honest i was
thrown away from school at the age of 14
and a half probably
yeah yeah so i had to study by myself
and learn by myself and
i just couldn't stand the i guess the
structured
organizational education system in
israel back then
and i'm also uh i guess i'm a hardcore
auto deduct
i learn by myself and i'm also uh i got
dyslexia
so it's a bad combination to be in an
organized
i guess education system when you have
this kind of a two combinations
and then so even after 14 and a half
year you go to the open university for
your bachelor's and your master's and
you know the open university i remember
from from my army days
i had a bunch of soldiers that were
doing the open university how difficult
it is because
essentially it's self-teaching you know
across
two degrees it sounds like from what you
did and so it's
it's quite a challenge i'm assuming so
honestly i can't stand learning in a
structural processing
of any kind of education so for me it
was just a relief
i finally was able to to to shine by
studying by myself
you don't have anyone to hold you up or
to push you too much
and you know most of the things to be
honest you can easily learn by yourself
when it comes to computer science
but there are several things when i took
it also to the physics part and to the
uh i guess hardcore engineering you know
like rf
rf radio frequencies is something much
harder to study by yourself without any
help but
but i guess that was the the best uh
optimized process for me learned by
myself study by myself
for some people it might be hard for me
learning in a group
is the harder part is that a
you know self-learning and this
independence this idea that
you don't need to rely on the work done
by previous
people is that is that a you know a seed
that was planted for you knowing that
you're going to be
an entrepreneur in whatever you do
across the different
projects you're going to be doing you
know now we we we take
the world and the word entrepreneur and
a startup for granted
back then is well maybe i'll start
something
i even didn't know i was an entrepreneur
until my third startup company
you know it's a and back then we didn't
call it startup we called a company
maybe we'll start a company you know it
was never a startup or anything like
that
we even didn't get to the understanding
of raising money
you know i it sounds like i'm 80 years
old but i'm not i'm talking about you
know the early 90s the late 90s
back then it was very something exciting
you know for for me growing up
my romance way of thinking was i wanted
to be a developer
i wanted to be an assembly developer
i wanted to be a c a little bit later it
wasn't about anything else
you know things that we used to do when
it comes to developing was
writing the code by ourself how can i
manage the memory by myself how can i
energy
manage the cpu reads now if any
developer
touches those components i'm gonna slap
him you know don't do that the compiler
is amazing he's doing it in the best
possible way but
for that for for us for i guess my older
generation that we're really tacky
really
geeky pure development
was the ideal i guess way of thinking
but when you play a lot of games growing
up and
back then games were not the games we
see today you know
pre-playstation it was nintendo and a
little bit vga games and something like
that
so you very quickly thinks about wait i
can do something much more interesting
and i guess the first innovation in the
first i guess
entrepreneurship point of ma of the wave
that i was thinking about
how can i make just a new game how can i
make something new that
because i just don't enjoy what i have
available today
but let's be honest i wasn't in a
playstation generation yes
now there is so much abundance of things
that are available for us so
we think about things differently
you know one of the things that i just
love so much about you know this project
is that
i come into this conversation thinking
wow i'm gonna spend 20 minutes talking
about accessibility and health tech and
bina ai and this awesome company
and we dive into this you know
philosophical question of what does it
really mean to be an entrepreneur
and that's i i i get inspired by by
these
you know experiences that are so genuine
simply this idea that
i i'm not satisfied with what's around
me i want to be satisfied and so
perhaps i can use my skills to create a
new better world around me for myself
and for many many others
but fast forwarding now for sure to be
not ai
you've been working on this for five
years you know this past year and a half
literally the headline every day for
in the in the new york times has been
centered around healthcare
and the digital transformations that i'm
guessing hundreds of thousands of
clinics around the world
had to make and i'm thinking well you
started this five years ago
you know what is vinaya and where did it
catch you
when covet 19 started i i want to get
also to that day
where you understood like wow this is
what we're meant to do
you know i think that a lot of people
trying to think about the lessons we'll
learn from the pandemic
you know so i think that the the core
three things
that i see that we've learned is first
of all
is that we are much more fragile than we
thought we are
extremely fragile and you know when we
started bina we didn't
we we came to this understanding that
remote care
is the future because not just because
we had a hunch
you know if we take a look at the
reports of the uh world health
organization from 2017
2018 and 2019 they came to a very sad
conclusion that about half of the world
lacks access to essential health
services half
of the world you know we live in this
kind of a half
of the world i'm not kidding man this is
serious numbers
you can check it out i feel like to
pause that this statement because
we throw statistics all the time half
of the world on blacks access to
essential
health services you know in the in the
western world in the modern world we
live in a place whether you're in in
in san francisco in israel you have on
an average about three doctors for every
thousand people
let's go to africa we're talking about
one doctor for every
50 000 people for every 100th
papua new guinea in the entire papua new
guinea 13 million people
they have 486 doctors
no yes and actually it's not just
in in extremely developing countries but
take a look on the
uh on the rural side of china there's
still places when you have one doctor
for
every 10 000 people 12 000 people 20
000 people take a look at india what's
happening there for god's sake
i really send my my my best wishes to
india to to go through this phase and
that's
horrifying of course but when thinking
about those kind of numbers
and that it's actually going to get much
worse within the next eight and a half
years by 2030
we're gonna have lacking of 15 million
medical professionals nurses and doctors
and everything
so it's going to get worse so we thought
about
how everything in any kind of a medical
consultation any kind of a physician
meeting everything starts with the most
basic fundamentals how can i know
how exactly you're feeling because even
though feeling is something emotional
many times but eventually our body
is a machine and any kind of a meeting
with a doctor starts with the ability of
just extracting the most basic vital
signs
heart rate oxygen saturation respiration
rate
heart rate variability blood pressure
and all those kind of vital signs are
the key
i guess component of any kind of a
medical consultation and we thought that
this kind of capability should be
available
anywhere and i think that the the core
of understanding and you know
just in a few seconds we'll get to the
pandemic but
i guess this kind of a self-care
self-observation
having talking with a doctor and we're
able to extract those kind of vital
signs this is the basic of everything
and when pandemic hits you know on
february
last year uh who would have believed it
a year
and a half almost a year and a half
later and we're still talking about that
but when when it started we sort of
under
p the humanity understood that self-care
is is not it's not being spoiled it's
something that everyone needs
how everyone actually needs that today
not only that we couldn't get to
hospitals maybe we were just scared
maybe
you know people would not accept us
without serious condition
but i think that the
the everywhere everywhere it means
work everywhere be everywhere it doesn't
matter where you are
you have to be able to get medical
consultation
you have to be able to get
self-observation in order to know
exactly how you're feeling
and we thought about that only from the
telemedicine perspective you know
telemedicine is booming now worldwide
you see companies raising billions of
dollars in order to provide
remote telemedicine services from our
point of view
is about how you can make telemedicine
exactly
like you're in the physician office you
know today whether you're getting a
video consultation session a person just
can ask you okay how you're feeling
what's wrong with you
maybe if you have some sort of a rash
you can show it over the camera and the
doctor will be able to see it but
besides that
nothing everything is about just asking
you oh
i have this pain in my eye
maybe but whenever a doctor can actually
extract vital signs even
during a video consultation session
everything changes
everything you know a doctor can
actually help you
and you know we started this
conversation with with healthcare about
countries that don't have any medical
services
but let's go to new york you know new
york
ground zero when it comes to humanity
today
still when you need to schedule a call
or a session with a doctor you wait for
two weeks
and that's why telemedicine is booming
you can actually have a video
consultation sometimes within minutes
and if the doctor can actually get your
vital signs you can make the
right decision and let's say i had a
great call with the doctor he
you've seen my vital signs he gave me
the best recommendation
two days later how can you know that
you're actually getting better according
to the recommendation
so get your vital signs scan again you
can see whether you're getting better
or maybe you're getting worse and you
should reschedule a call i know i'm i'm
throwing a lot of data to you but
you know i'm just extremely excited
about what we're doing because
you know in in in the early 2000s the
major company that truly
blew up are companies that had an impact
and i truly believe that this is a
serious impact about
humanity and about everything at first
you know when we went
out before the pandemic everyone would
thought well
they're helping insurance company
knowing if we're sick and we won't be
able to get insurance
no it was never about that but when
we're talking about industries
that their entire risk assessment is
based on knowing how you're feeling
yes we also have some of the largest
insurance companies as customers
but it was never about helping insurance
companies
it was helping to have remote care
available
anywhere to anyone at any time
the only thing i want to wish for myself
coming out of this conversation is that
one day when i'll
run a company and i'll sit in your seat
and i will be interviewed i will have
that energy
and that passion and excitement to to
to talk the way that you talk because
that really is the essence of what i'm
trying to get here and
and i think it's just completely
inspiring that that five years later
you're still you're so convinced
to the to your core and i can feel it at
how important the mission is and it
sounds like you were
convinced way before the pandemic and
now the world has caught on and
understood
that wow we have a really big problem
here
and and a really big wake-up call now
tell me a little bit
more tangibly you know solving what this
this incredibly challenging problem
you know bridging the gap from the you
know the
telemedicine to the physical world you
know finding
some sort of weird intersection with for
example with vital signs
how does that actually work how how do
you make that
intersection let's take it down to
basics the most basic things that we are
doing we are able to use
almost any device with a camera you know
a smartphone
a laptop a tablet any device with a
camera and using the camera we're able
to extract vital signs and how we do
that
just in a in a very high level so you
know any kind of a smart watch that
you're
having you're able to see those kind of
a blinking light at the back of your
smartwatch
and those blinking lights actually using
the same technology for the past 80
years ppg
photopolystymography which basically
means you're sending a light beam to the
skin
you're seeing the blood flow behind the
skin and then you can estimate
things like heart rate and other things
of observations
what we're doing we're able to analyze
the light reflection intensity from the
environment
that comes back from your face skin to
the camera
lens and by analyzing that and that's a
lot of signal processing capabilities a
lot of cleanup a lot of screening a lot
of filtering a lot of
very interesting and exciting technology
we're able to get the exact same
signal quality over 30 db of ppg
just from the person's face so basically
exactly like the oxymeters that you put
on your finger or the apple watch
we're getting the same signal quality
just from
the camera and having the ability to
have this kind of information in your
face and
now we went to move to something much
more exciting how we can analyze
multiple locations in your face to get
multiple ppg
and then we can get ptt to anyone who's
interesting about that and then we can
get
so much more cool information just from
the person's face it's very important to
say that
we're never analyzing facial expressions
or eye motion or anything like that
everything is about just getting
good pieces of skin that have good light
reflection
and to get the ppg once we have that
then the fun
starts we're able to transform it to
multiple types of vital signs
we're able to get extremely interesting
insights
about the person's physical condition
and
to provide it to whoever wishes so i
think that's
the most basic core thing you have a
camera we will be able to extract vital
signs that's how
easy it is and and i think one of the
most important pieces of the puzzle here
is
the timing of this because it sounds
like you have an incredible team and an
incredible product with incredible
technology
you still need people to have cameras
and what we've been saying in the past
six and seven years is we've been seeing
the dissemination of smartphones
you know in places where they might not
have clean water but they have a
smartphone
which is you know something that's
that's you know a little hard to grasp
at least in my mind uh yet it's it's
a you know it makes perfect sense why
this is you know the right time the
right place
and it sounds like you're working on
some really really incredible things
david i'm so sad that i called this show
20 minute leaders are not 30 minute
leaders because i have about
30 more questions i need to ask you but
i do have a few
fun questions for you before we go
please
all right favorite subject i guess in
middle school because i don't think you
made it to high school so we'll go with
middle school
yeah sort of middle school and just the
beginning of high school so
i guess i had two very interesting
subjects that i was always after
i guess one was classical physics i'm
talking about classical you know energy
force
nothing have to do with quantum
mechanics or anything like that
that was always interesting and the
second subject was about
how not to be in school what can i do in
order not to stay in school so
that was also a very interesting subject
for me
i love it somebody that you look up to
somebody that you know
inspires you on a regular basis some
sort of a role model
uh you know the easiest answer will be
elon musk
steve jobs i don't care i love them and
i admire them in some way but
they're they were those are not people
that i uh
i guess admire to to the heart there are
several
very interesting people but i think i
really admire my parents that they were
able to stick with me
and uh my wife i guess i admire my wife
as well
and several people from the history that
people don't really know you know for
example
uh there was a really interesting rabbi
i'm not a religious guy but i really
love
smart people it doesn't matter whether
they're christian or
jewish but there was a very interesting
guy from the 1850s that was called
rabbi menachem mendel from and
you should really read quotes that this
guy said but he said something really
interesting he said
things that come from the heart enters
the heart
but also from the heart that they came
out from
and that means just you know say good
things not only for the other side
side to to get them into their heart but
also for you
to to understand that it's so important
anyhow i really like him
i love it and three words you would use
to describe yourself
i guess i'm
a common people you know i'm a common
guy
i know that a lot of people see it as a
joke but i really think that i'm a
common guy
uh three words i guess uh
loving everything is about love love
what you do love the people love your
co-workers love your parents love i'm a
loving guy
i'm an extremely intrigued guy i find
everything interesting and the third
thing is that
passion i guess
david after i just want to be your
friend so
we are friends already come on there you
go
david thank you so much for taking time
out of your busy schedule to be here
my pleasure i really appreciate it i i
i'm living here with so much more energy
than when i came in with
you know both the you know the
philosophical question of
entrepreneurship moving on to this idea
of
you know we have this global problem
that is you know that is really
difficult but there is
a bunch of circumstances that are
allowing for a wonderful team to come
and
and create really meaningful technology
to help transform it and i feel like
we're only starting to see
to see the seeds of it and i cannot wait
to see where this goes and and how this
is going to transform both my life but
also the lives of
billions of others that aren't as
fortunate to be living in in a you know
in
developed area that have this axis so
david thank you
so so much thank you very much for
having me have a wonderful day in
jacksonville of course
thank you thank you thank you bye